as you can tell i'm in a really good
mood because um
i know just every day more and more
vaccines
are rolling out that just fills me
with joy it's really great isn't it andy
yeah you know in fact
i got my vaccine yesterday you're
kidding
that's fantastic that's that's such
great did you get it down at dodger
stadium
nope uh did you get it at one of those
uh pop-up locations
no no huh so like a pharmacy like
walgreens or cvs yeah
yeah it was it was a cvs oh you know i'm
just curious
i've not had my vaccine yet what's that
process like do you have to call in the
morning and like make an appointment
no i mean i parked in the cvs parking
lot around 3am and i i barely
had to wait i just flashed my high beams
three times like they told me and a
couple guys came right over and gave me
the vaccine
a couple of guys yeah although
technically they didn't
give me the vaccine they made me do it
myself something about liability
but you know they did tell me exactly
how to do it and one of them even let me
borrow his belt to tie it around my arm
you know it takes a village i guess
andy i don't think you got the vaccine i
think you might have done heroin
what i don't think so i mean
if it was heroin why did i feel so great
right after i threw up
because heroin is a very powerful drug
andy
no it was definitely the vaccine okay
well
which one was it was it pfizer moderna
was it johnson and johnson johnson and
johnson although
only one of the guys was named johnson
the other guy was named spider
i think and they had all the vaccines
they had
moderna pfizer dragon ball uh midnight
duchess scorpion by
titty cloud okay andy i'm sorry my
assumption is those are all types of
heroin
whichever vaccine was i don't have to
wait three stupid weeks for my second
shot
spider said i could come back tonight
for another vaccine which is
uh pretty great news because so far the
only side effect
i have is that i want more vaccine in
fact can i cut out early today and go
get
no no do not do not go back there andy
don't go back there you're just
they're just gonna give you more heroin
how do you know so much
i mean wait did you get it too are you
holding conan
cause i need some more of that sweet
vaccine i am sick daddy i'm real sick
yeah because two strangers gave you
heroin in a cvs parking lot
now your body's experiencing withdrawal
andy
you know what you might be right you
know instead of taking the covet vaccine
i think
i might have done heroin andy
you know what this sounds like to me a
classic
mix-up this classic mix-up brought to
you by holloway's old-fashioned
bridge mix mix it up
i did heroin
[Music]
again
you